vous mauvais choix très mauvais choix
alors je dis avance que je vais préciser
bravo aux personnages bilan je le
soutiens totalement face aux messages
honteux de haine qu'il peut recevoir
celui mais la chanson cyril c'est une
daube internationale je n'ai jamais vu
pire merde j'ai connu je ne connais rien
je suis en concert je me connais et tu
me donnes périple madame monsieur mais
peut-être c'est un duo de bobos qui
emmerdent qu'elle adore mon fils n'a
aucun talent et vous en bien entendu pas
le juré les jurés internationaux
d'ailleurs l'on classé cinquième
seulement ça va pas du tout prendre il
chante en français en anglais
cette chanson c'est un os fera à
l'entente ya france télévisions qui nous
regardent des prêts prendre aux civils
en syrie tué sévère avec destination aux
visions la finale est en forte
progression d'une semaine sur l'autre et
sur un an 12 % en mai à cannes on est un
peu en retrait par rapport à la casse
mais très bons résultats auprès des
cibles moins 35 ans avec moustache et
portant des chaussures c'est un des
patrons de posséder des biens des
viandes
ils sont plutôt assez content des scores
apparemment et ben il chérit basse et
bien mettre trois semaines de suite je
pense qu'on aurait pu faire plus si
c'était moi j'ai moi ce qui m'a ce qui
m'a rendu fou c'est que il faut mettre
des champions ils ont fait chanter ou
genre à emmanuel mois ils ont fait
chanter sur une chanson de la suède
venait de 2008 faites lui chantait son
tube si vous devez gagner du temps on
admettre une chanson qu'on connaît pas
bande de roanne voilà mais c'est rigolo
c'est un truc de fou ça oui oui après
jeu également d'abord nous le dira
personnage attachant et émouvant mais on
cherche pas un meilleur ami on cherche
pas la nouvelle star de youtube
qu'est ce qu'on cherche un chanteur
l'eurovision il ya un concours de chant
je m'excuse je l'aï fait vous savez pas
chanter mais justement
mais justement série de jeux je m'y
connais en fausse note et m'excuse
c'était faux alors moi je suis pas
d'accord avec avec gilles je trouve que
la chanson est plutôt joli mais je
trouve qu'il a été plusieurs fois mais
comparé à d'autres qu'on d'autres
personnes qui étaient là emmanuel moire
chimène badi il était moins bon après le
personnage est attachant les gens voient
des prix mais c'est injuste
l'émission était une torpeur mais ce
n'est pas le débat on voit ce qu'on
cherche c'est un personnage c'est un
message à faire passer dans une mare
wolf
c'était une belle voix de france c'est
un message c'est un personnage c'est une
personnalité jamais à l'eurovision on a
fait des tubes
colossaux et certainement pas en france
donc ça colle complètement à ce que veut
la société aujourd'hui donc tu veux
quelqu'un chanter carolinum et loïc
sécher au play on n'est pas chez bd
missiles et deux mois ce four c'est un
très bon choix on se fourvoie chaque
année en envoyant leur vision des
chansons qui sont un peu dépressif
franco française voilà c'est une chanson
qui est international c'est un choix
mais qu'ils ont vois tu la retient tout
de suite la chanson te dire tout va
chanter je pense et nos meilleures
chances de pim donc moins de 20 ans dit
non madame je trouvais que c'était un
bon choix pour le base un mauvais choix
pour la chanson et plus je l'entends
hélas plus je commence avec la turquie
n'aura pas non plus
vision it réseau chaque année vous dites
ça sert il chaque année vous dit
sebastian et je dis que je vais vous
virer aussi il ya une année